see everyone talks about oh meet the
parents so you need to make a good
impression no what if they need to make
a good impression on you
[Music]
hey guys it's sarah hyland here my name
is karen robinson i'm sammer salem i'm
dylan sprouse i'm marcus rosner i'm
keenan lonsdale i play andrew in
buzzfeed's next feature film my fake
boyfriend my fake boyfriend but today we
are answering some of your most pressing
dating questions pressing questions
about dating
things like that
the man should pay now that's that now
that's how i feel but when i was younger
i was like i'm my own woman
i'm paying for everything myself
now i'm like no dream like a queen of
swank
like to put on the first date i think
it's a nice way to show somebody that
you care i like to always offer up that
i'm gonna pay i'm always a 50 50 guy you
know what equal rights
[Music]
you could be messaging and you could end
up meeting that day you know if it feels
right if you're
excited enough i've done that before
i guess wells and i
met in this similar way of a dating app
where you're talking online
and then you meet each other later the
sooner the better it's hard to get a
sense of who someone really is over
texting you should really pay attention
to the vibe you know like once we're in
person that the conversation like
actually flows and not just like a text
message conversation maybe while the
iron's hot don't let it simmer out
keep that passion alive
see each other
[Music]
run i would say run
i don't think that social media equates
to being a real couple i gotta be real
with you i don't put any of uh any
photos or videos much of my fiance on my
feed so i certainly hope that doesn't
mean it's not a real relationship if
he's trying to hide you in real life and
also trying to hide you online i think
that's a red flag if it's something that
you want to have happen and your
boyfriend is not agreeable to it and you
get that little voice in the back of
your head telling you that something's
up something's up
[Music]
wait for it
take your time
cry as much as you need to find somebody
to talk to and you know safe casual sex
that helps but it doesn't usually um
really fill the void getting under
someone else get the best way to get
over get under
drinking and uh finding a new
relationship
[Music]
at least
six months just meet him
say what's up make sure you bring gifts
in my mind it's like when you've
exchanged i love yous and you know it's
for real then i think it's a good time
to talk about meeting each other's
parents
[Music]
wells adams is my fiance i don't know
trust
communication
comfort
adventure and uh
and sex
i think if i could define love in five
words i would be a famous poet
person who makes me laugh
[Music]
i would say don't fake a boyfriend just
go get a hot new piece of ass
dangle it in front of them
it will probably come back around there
will be some kind of repercussions of
that
so yeah it's okay but you're gonna deal
with it in some way
yes
get revenge
thank you for watching thank you
buzzfeed please check out my fake
boyfriend bye